HOMICIDE, ASSAULT, THREATENING
THE FAMILY MEMBER OF A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL AS WELL AS ELDER ABUSE.
>> JOSH CAMPBELL ON THE SCENE
FOR US, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE PELOSI ATTACK IS RAMPING UP
FEARS OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES IN AN
ALREADY DIVISIVE CLIMATE RIGHT
HERE IN THE NATION'S CAPITAL,
WASHINGTON.
THERE'S A CLEAR PARTISAN SPLIT
ON WHETHER REPUBLICAN
CONDEMNATION OF SPEAKER PELOSI
SPURRED HER HUSBAND'S ATTACKER
TO ACT.
MELANIE ZANONIS IS JOINING US
RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS HAVE
PUBLICLY CONDEMNED THE VIOLENCE
BUT SOME ARE ACTUALLY MAKING
JOKES ABOUT IT.
>> Reporter: YEAH, THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT, WOLF.
INSTEAD OF THIS MOMENT OF UNITY,
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS REPUBLICANS
ACTUALLY MOCKING PAUL PELOSI AND
THE ATTACK.
IN FACT DONALD TRUMP JR. TWEETED
OUT SOME REALLY CRUDE MEMES
MAKING FUN OF PAUL PELOSI AND
THE INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED.
AND THEN YOU HAVE KARI LAKE, THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR ARIZONA
GOVERNOR, WHO HAD THIS TO SAY AT
A CAMPAIGN EVENT EARLIER TODAY.
>> IT IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
PROTECT OUR KIDS AT SCHOOL.
THEY ACT LIKE IT IS.
NANCY PELOSI -- WELL, SHE'S GOT
PROTECTION WHEN SHE'S IN --
APPARENTLY HER HOUSE DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF PROTECTION.
>> Reporter: NOW, I WOULD SAY
MOST REPUBLICANS HAVE CONDEMNED
THE ATTACK, BUT A LOT OF THEM
HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME OF THE
GOP'S OWN RHETORIC OR THEIR
EFFORTS TO DEMONIZE NANCY PELOSI
OR THEIR PARTY'S EMBRACE OF
FRINGE CONSPIRACY THEORIES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DANGEROUS,
TOXIC POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
OR THEY HAVE TRIED TO BLAME BOTH
SIDES ACTUALLY.
THEN RONNA McDANIEL TOLD FOX
NEWS IT WAS EVEN UNFAIR TO
SUGGEST THAT POLITICAL RHETORIC
CONTRIBUTED TO THE ATTACK IN ANY
WAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I THINK THAT'S UNFAIR.
I THINK THIS IS A DERANGED
INDIVIDUAL.
YOU CAN'T SAY PEOPLE SAYING
LET'S FIRE PELOSI OR LET'S TAKE
BACK THE HOUSE IS SAYING GO DO
VIOLENCE.
IT'S JUST UNFAIR.
>> Reporter: MEANWHILE GOP
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY WAS
INITIALLY PUBLICLY SILENT ABOUT
THE ATTACK BUT HE DID COME OUT
ON SATURDAY AND CONDEMNED THE
ATTACK AND ALL FORMS OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
BUT HE DID TRY TO PORTRAY THE
ATTACK AS A BROADER CRIME ISSUE.
HOWEVER, THERE IS AT LEAST ONE
REPUBLICAN WHO DISAGREES WITH
HIM AND THAT IS FRED UPTON.
HE IS ONE OFTON HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH
TRUMP.
HE HIMSELF HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT
OF THREATS.
HE TOLD ME THAT HE DOES BELIEVE
HIS PARTY DOES BEAR SOME
RESPONSIBILITY, THAT SOME OF
THESE PELOSI ATTACK ADS HAVE
GONE TOO FAR AND THE DONALD
TRUMP TWEETS WERE DISGUSTING.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, HE IS THE
MINORITY VOICE IN THIS PARTY.
>> MELANIE, THANKS VERY MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN OUR LEGAL, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND POLITICAL
EXPERTS.
SHAN WU, AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE SERIOUSNESS OF PAUL PELOSI'S
INJURIES AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE ATTACK, DO YOU EXPECT
ADDITIONAL CHARGES MAY BE ADDED?
>> WELL, THE CHARGES THEY HAVE
ALREADY HIT HIM WITH ARE QUITE
SERIOUS AND WOULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT JAIL TIME LIKELY.
ON TOP OF THAT, I'M EXPECTING
THERE WILL BE STATE CHARGES
FILED TOO.
THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
ADDITIONAL CHARGES, DEPENDING ON
WHAT ELSE THEY FIND.
AND AT THE SENTENCING STAGE WHEN
THEY GET THERE, THEY COULD
ACTUALLY SEEK AN ENHANCEMENT FOR
DOMESTIC TERRORISM CHARGE HERE.
BUT THESE CHARGES ARE ALREADY
VERY SIGNIFICANT.
THEY SEEM RIGHT ON TARGET.
AND DOJ HAS SEEMED A LITTLE
RELUCTANT TO USE THAT
ENHANCEMENT, AT LEAST WHEN IT
COMES TO THE JANUARY 6th
RIOTERS.
THEY PREFERRED TO GO WITH THE
MORE STRAIGHT-AHEAD ASSAULT,
TRESPASS, DESTRUCTION OF
PROPERTY.
THEY SEEM TO BE DOING THAT HERE.
BUT AGAIN, THESE ARE VERY
SERIOUS FEDERAL CHARGES.
>> JOHN MILLER, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF HOW FORTHCOMING THE SUSPECT
WAS IN HIS INTERVIEW WITH
POLICE.
HE WAS READ HIS MIRANDA RIGHTS
BUT SPOKE EXTENSIVELY TO THE
POLICE.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU BASED ON
THIS AFFIDAVIT THAT HAS NOW BEEN
RELEASED?
>> SO MANY THINGS, WOLF.
IT'S A VERY RICH AFFIDAVIT IN
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY PUT IN
ABOUT THEIR EVIDENCE.
BUT LET'S GO BACK TO OUR SUSPECT
FOR A MINUTE TO GET TO THE CORE
OF YOUR QUESTION.
HERE'S A GUY WHO WAS INVOLVED IN
A HIGH-RISK ACTIVITY.
HE'S GOING TO DO A HOME INVASION
BY HIMSELF WITH A HAMMER AT THE
HOME OF ARGUABLY THE SECOND MOST
POWER OF PERSON IN THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT IN THE LINE OF
SUCCESSION FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
SO THERE IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
RISK THAT ANY RATIONAL THINKER
WOULD CALCULATE THAT HE'S GOING
TO GET CAUGHT.
AND YET WHEN HIS VICTIM CALLS
THE POLICE AND HE KNOWS IT WAS
911 AND HE KNOWS THE POLICE ARE
COMING, HE DOES NOT FLEE.
HE COMPARES HIMSELF IN A BIZARRE
STATEMENT TO BEING LIKE OUR
FOREFATHERS WHO FOUGHT THE
BRITISH.
SURRENDER WAS NOT AN OPTION.
SO YOU HAVE A GUY WHO TOOK THE
RISK OF GETTING CAUGHT, THEN
KNEW HE WAS GOING TO GET CAUGHT
AND THEN GOT CAUGHT AND THEN
GAVE HIS STATEMENTS TO POLICE.
SO HE'S LIVING OUT LOUD DURING
THIS EPISODE.
AND I THINK HE WANTS TO BE
KNOWN.
HE WANTS HIS VOICE TO BE HEARD.
AND, YOU KNOW, T